put 50 up for sale on that Wednesday
having promoted it I think on the Monday
and we sold the first 50 in like under a
minute and we were like okay this is a
thing everyone from like the Spice Girls
to stormy to all these people made these
kits it was huge on Instagram and uh it
saved the company this is an interview
between me and Tom Elliot who is the
co-founder of the really successful
pizza chain of pizza pilgrims it's
incredibly exciting because Pizza
pilgrims has been around now for 10
years and it actually started on a bit
of a whim when Tom and his brother
decided that they were going to quit
their corporate jobs that they didn't
enjoy and they were going to do a little
pilgrimage to Italy to learn about how
pizzas are being made and then while in
Italy they bought a pizza van they drove
it all the way back to the UK and they
started their first store in 2012 we
were like obsessed with pizza that's
that's the thing that's what we're going
to do to break into this world then
obviously after we'd come down off that
initial high it was like oh we know
nothing about pizza at all we have no
skills no understanding we need to
figure it out so that's when we realized
that we needed to go to Italy to
understand what it's all about and so in
this very wide ranging conversation we
talked about how they took that plunge
initially to quit their boring corporate
jobs and do this Rogue thing like
starting a pizza business we talk about
some of the challenges of
Entrepreneurship as it relates to having
a food business and all of the various
different issues and challenges
associated with that and Tom shares a
bunch of really really helpful advice
that's useful for me and that's useful
for any entrepreneur whatever stage of
the journey you're at if you have that
thing in you whatever that is to want
start a business I just think you've got
to go for it early like if you're going
to do it do it as early as you possibly
can it annoys me that we don't encourage
people straight after levels definitely
straight off University to go and have a
crack or something this episode is
sponsored by kajabi and they've actually
got something really valuable for all of
our Deep dive listeners now if you
haven't heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 201 23 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion to creators that's billion
with a be and over a thousand creators
have become million millionaires through
products on the platform now back in May
2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi in real
life kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas
and in that keynote I talked about the
exact steps that I use to grow my
business from zero to over $2.5 million
per year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well and you
just enter your email address and then
you will get the recording of that
keynote completely for free whether or
not you ever become a kajabi customer so
thank you so much to kajabi for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by none other
than hu now I've been a pain customer of
hu since 2017 I first discovered it in
my 5ifth year of medical school and if
you haven't heard of it it's basically a
meal in a bottle and in that meal you
get a balanced mixture of carbohydrates
and fats and proteins and fi F and it
also contains 26 different vitamins and
minerals and each meal has around 400
calories and 22 g of protein so it's
pretty reasonable in terms of protein
count and because I tend to be pretty
busy and there's always stuff going on I
tend not to really have time to get a
healthy breakfast or a healthy lunch and
so I'll often use hu ready to drink as a
replacement for my breakfast or my lunch
they've got eight different flavors that
are available my two favorites are
banana and salted caramel so if you find
those you should check them out and even
though hu as a company started off
online director consumer recently
they've propagated amongst all of like
the grocery stores in the UK at least
and so I've been seeing it out and about
everywhere which is pretty cool and very
excitingly we also have an episode with
Julian Hearn who is the founder of hu
back on this podcast from season 1 and
so that episode was a real masterclass
entrepreneurship and it was really cool
seeing kind of hearing the story of
exactly how heel came together so head
over to heel.com deepdive and thank you
so much heel for sponsoring this episode
this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone on the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
pie might be like I don't know 20% Apple
20% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that P looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multi currency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or us dos so if any of
that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of100 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading to on for sponsoring this
episode Tom welcome to the podcast thank
you for coming on um so you quit your
job and started a pizza company which
has now just celebrated its 10 year
anniversary so that's all really Rogue
what was the what was the origin story
how did how did you get started I love
how success in restaurants these days is
just survival like that is literally
like high five everyone 10 years uh but
no it was it was a it's been a mad
Journey it was
um I worked in advertising I started the
company with my brother I have to admit
it was his idea I was very much the sort
of enabler of his idea but um yeah I was
working in advertising my brother was
working in TV production we had grown up
literally above a pub our parents had
run a pub we had lived above it and sort
of had that sort of hospitality thing in
our veins and yeah we had both been in
London for sort of five seven years
doing jobs that we really didn't enjoy
didn't get a kick out of at all had
tried a couple of times to like maybe
start a pu of Our Own but we had no
Capital we had no kind of experience so
no one would have backed us um and so we
were sort of a bit sort of stuck I guess
and then just out of nowhere like a sort
of an amazing Revelation this this food
truck street food Revolution happened in
in London and suddenly it was possible
to you know create a credible quality Le
brand but have no capital and start it
in the back of a food truck what do you
mean you can start a food Business
Without so like honestly I I genuine
believe and this is like me kind of
getting carried away with myself but I
think in the sort of world of food which
does like to kind of like self-reflect
quite a lot in 50 years time we'll look
back on like 2010 to
2012 very much how we look back on like
1961 to 1963 in music terms just like a
sort of an explosion of like
creativity all the right things and all
the right places Twitter Just Landing
street food trucks becoming a thing uh
obviously just off the back of a big
recession so lots of people having lost
their jobs looking to kind of start a
fresh and I still think in London
particularly like so many of the Great
brands that went on to become something
bigger all started in that time like
your dumes your flat irons your ptin
buns your honest Burgers you know
Caravan I mean this you could go on
forever there are so many Fantastic
brands that like started in that moment
um and but our particular way in was was
street food and it was like I said we
were looking around for a way to get in
I mean restaurants famously they require
R of capital they require you to put
quite a lot on the line cuz you got to
build the bloody thing before you even
open it yeah and suddenly there was an
opportunity to you know we we were going
we were like traveling across London
having seen on Twitter that there was
you know this meat wagon in um in in a
car park in New Cross or pekam or
whatever and you'd go and there' be you
know potentially hundreds of people
waiting to try a burger excited excited
about the product like a product Le
business um all driven by Twitter like
this sort of like you know it's going to
be gone tomorrow so we've got to go now
type feeling and you know it was it was
a genuine thing and yeah that was
another one meet meet wagon became uh
meat easy became meat liquor and that
was you know one of the hottest
restaurant openings of 2013 probably so
we're in 2013 you and your brother are
working in the corporate jobs and in in
in your corporate jobs which which
you're not particularly enjoying yeah
how do you get from there to let's start
with food truck like that still feels a
bit it and there was a huge amount of
like I mean everyone a lot of ey rolls I
Rays a lot of like okay here's another
person who's lost their mind um but I
mean the short version is that we really
wanted to do it we were trying to find a
way into the food business my brother
went and did for his 21st birthday which
had been a few years earlier he'd went
he'd gone and done like a sort of
cookery class in Italy which had had
been paid for by his grandmother and we
he'd seen basically that everyone had
pizza rubbens in their Gardens and
instead of a barbecue people had a pizza
Roven uh so then we had an idea we'd
start a pizza Roven company and like put
pizza Rens into people Gardens then
Jamie Oliver did that so we were like
okay feel like feel like he's got this
one so but the of idea of pizza remained
then we had this kind of street food
element so you know going down to meet
wagon going to King's cross and seeing
the guys on each Street and like you
know chatting to all those guys about
you know some of them were doing Pella
some of them were doing hot dogs and you
know understanding that life and just
again seeing that like you know they
were building real brands that had real
Twitter following and had real people
that came back every week to try it um
and we looked at that scene and we were
like no one's doing Pizza that seems
insane as like one of the world's great
if not the world of great food stuff why
is no one doing Pizza turns out the
reason you're doing Pizza is because you
have to buy a massive great oven which
cost you thousands of pounds and you got
to carry the bloody thing around so uh
so that was the reason why yeah we were
like obsessed with pizza that's that's
the thing that's the thing that's going
to that's that's what we're going to do
to break into this world uh then
obviously after we'd come down off that
initial high it was like oh we know
nothing about pizza at all we have no no
skills no understanding we need to
figure it out so that's when we realize
that we needed to go to Italy to
understand you know birthplace of pizza
to understand what it's all about so
okay
question would love to dive into the
pizza stuff but I'm still intrigued like
you're like I don't enjoy my job yeah uh
a lot like you could start a software
business you could start a YouTube
channel you could start a what any
anything other than a food business like
what was it about the food business that
made you think that's the thing we want
to do I think it is just that like
genuinely it's just that
little human interaction thing of like
giving someone a little bit of Joy yeah
and we still try and do that like street
food is the most perfect distillation of
that there's no business in the world
really where someone comes up to you
kind of like you know Fisher Price
Fisher Price business someone comes up
to you and goes can I have that thing
that you sell here's a crisp 5 note you
go away you make it for them to order
you then give it to them and then you
watch you watch them eat it yeah and
it's this glorious feedback loop of like
you can actually ask them what they
thought you can learn from it you kind
of get this you know it's got this real
kind of immediacy energy that you just
cannot get from anything digital or you
know it's just it's just real there's
just no I mean that sounds so incredibly
cringe where they when I say it but no
not at all it's it's quite inspiring
really like it's so true cuz like there
there's no other business where you
literally make the thing and just give
it to them except maybe like build a
bear or something yeah yeah build there
who doesn't wish they started that they
got good margins yeah yeah um so was it
the pub background that helped with this
or I think that's it I think it's a
little bit of you know we were in the
pub all the time I wor behind the bar
when I got old enough all that kind of
stuff so that kind of constant human
interaction I guess you kind of crave
and it does provide that um I think
there is just that that feeling that you
know I don't know hospit you feel like I
guess you'll feel like you're sort of
giving something back in some weird way
which totally not really but you are you
know you're you're meeting an absolutely
fundamental human need which is to eat
and hopefully meeting it in an elevated
way so it's like you're doing something
exciting I I honestly don't think I
could start a sushi business because I
just I I think cold food doesn't have
that same emotional driver that hot food
has true like you know I just don't
think you know it's always a choice that
you're doing because it's you're trying
to make a compromise you're trying to be
healthy you're trying to be fast whereas
I think like a hot cooked meal H it's
it's you know it's never going to go
away whenever you know even if we end up
in Ready Player one yeah you're still
going to want to take that headset off
and have a hot meal for sure and so yeah
I just I think you know at a very deep
level we certainly didn't think about it
this way at the time but a deep level
that was a thing we wanted you know we
wanted to be part of that I think it's
always you know with the street food
things particularly it's it's nice to be
part of a movement and like we we were
there not certainly not the earliest but
like very much early in that world and
still like you know we know all those
guys really well some of them have gone
on to like do restaurants some of them
are still doing the street food thing
you know I think we're both secretly
quite jealous of those of those guys
still doing the kind of street food
festivals life because it is it is just
it's it's hard work really hard work but
it's also like once it's stopped it's
stopped you're not sitting there going
like oh God got to do this or that or
the other it's you know you do your
festival and then you have a week off
and it's like nice to to what extent
would you recommend the food business
business if someone's listening to this
and let's say they're working a
corporate job and they're like you know
what I want to start a
business I actually know a lot of people
who are like oh I'd love to start a
burger van or something like that yeah
um would you to what extent would you
recommend it I would recommend it so
wholeheartedly if if okay it's for the
love because it is there is no doubt if
you're like I just want to make loads of
money fast food is the worst possible
way to do that it's incredibly
incredibly hard to like you know get
yourself going it's hard work it's
hugely rewarding
but not necessarily financially uh but
you know if if you if you want like a
lifestyle business or something that's
going to like just put you into
interesting situations with interesting
people or like throw crazy opportunities
you know that you never thought would
come your way and you're willing to work
hard and like put it put the time and
energy in I mean we you know we we've
just loved every minute of of of doing a
food business and yeah you
know I I really can't say any any
clearer than that nice okay so you
decide that you're going to start the
food business and you're like cool we
have to go to Italy yeah what happens
next what happens next so we we go to
Italy I weirdly email my boss in the
advertising agency being like I've heard
on the Great Vine we've not met but
you're you're starting a bakery in
Cambridge apparently you're leaving
start Bakery in Cambridge I'm leaving to
start Pizza Company we should going to
have a bit oh which Bakery was this uh
it's called
Uh can it's called really famous for
Chelsea buns called uh Cinnabon no no no
no no Fitz billies Fitz billies fits
billi your boss started fits billies so
Fitz billies is like an age- old
business okay I was going to say old is
it hundreds of years ago certainly tens
and tens of years ago it had fallen into
disrepair disrepute someone had given up
on it whatever it was like it was
available to be sold so in
2011 she had just bought it with her
husband and was like I'm going to
transform this business I've been to
fitzly so many times 2012 through 2018
when I back to cambrid just start us to
go to FZ Billy take my mom there the C
cinamon rolls with we we went recently
cuz we very recently opened the pizza
programs in Cambridge and we always go
on a little because basically I emailed
her not knowing her but saying like
you're obiously off to start this Bakery
uh she was like yeah absolutely we
should totally come for be why you come
to my house she lives in Camden let's go
go for a beer in Camden went to meet her
what I didn't know was her husband uh is
was the food critic for the financial
times oh this guy called Tim Haywood and
he's just he was the first person
basically who listen to our story our
idea the fact that we were going to
Italy and was like hell yes this is a
great idea I'm super psyched about this
he was like the first human being that
was like supportive of the plan so why
was he supportive of it like what was I
think he's just he's he's got sort of
this incredible like puppy like
enthusiasm about just everything to do
with like food and lifestyle and cool
stuff sorry that wasn't us don't worry
uh and uh yeah you know he's obviously
he's a food critic he's engaged with
exciting food things we were like
obviously excited to go and learn about
pizza and all that stuff and he was just
like this is an awesome idea you need to
make more of this pilgrimage this should
be a thing that you like really like
lean on and like get the most out of we
mostly H if we're honestly truthful the
reason we were doing the pilgrimage was
because it was cheaper to buy the van
that we wanted in Italy because it was
made in Italy than it was to get it you
can drive it across so we're like we'll
go we'll pick it up we'll drive it back
we'll save a load of money and in the
meantime we'll kind of try and learn a
bit about pizza but he was like you're
missing the point this is like this is
the best possible starting place for
your business okay why because he was
like this is your you know everyone
pizzza is the most saturated Market in
the world you've got to find a reason
why you're different yeah and at the
very least this is a fantastic story to
start off with like we went to it like
we went to it to learn okay and honestly
like that really you know the whole
thing was so unplanned un you know there
was no strategy it wasn't like oh we'll
do this in order to do this in order to
open a pizzeria I literally was like I
hate my job my brothers had this idea
I'm going to go and help him so at the
very least I've got out of advertising
in and I've done something like vaguely
productive yeah and then probably in a
year's time I'll go and like disappear
into the Shadows he can go and do that
and I'll go and find something else to
do were you in a TV show at one point so
so Tim being super enthusiastic about
the pizza was like you know this the
thing you need to make the most of my
brother worked in TV so we then
basically went away we wrote a pitch
literally two sides of A4 we sent it to
four production companies we sented like
optiman who a big big food production
company fresh one which Jamie oliv
production company uh a other and we
sent to a a fourth much smaller one
which is a friend a friend of a friend
of James's from TV called Rampage they
just started out anyway we went we sent
off this pitch to all these shows they
all came back being like we love this
idea we went and had meetings with all
of them but basically the bigger guys
you know um we sat with patellen who was
the she's the voice on the very original
Jamie Oliver shows she's like she
discovered Jamie Oliver and she was like
I love this idea I really want to do it
but you know it's July now you know
we're going to have to go away fully
plan it out then we have to go and
picture it stations like best case
scenario we're starting filming this in
18 months and I was like well we're
leaving in two months so we are doing it
now we're not doing it this is not about
the TV this is very much about the
business um so anyway didn't do it with
those guys Rampage we like look we'll
take a punt we'll do it without a TV
show a TV channel let's just freaking go
for it and so we kind of set off and and
made this slightly Random TV show where
we we took we elongated the pilgrimage
they kind of brought in some researchers
we ended up doing a lot more
stops uh and we made we made a TV show
which quite honestly was not a TV show
that we were excited by when when it
started to happen it was very clear that
like their Creative Vision and our
Creative Vision were very different they
were paying for it so we didn't really
and we were like right at the beginning
of everything we had no position to tell
them what to do and there was a TV show
made and you know the plus side was it
it gave us access that we couldn't have
Poss Poss imagined if we just rocked up
on our own so like you know we went to D
the you know the world famous pizzeria
in Naples and they let us like see the D
room and like get into the kitchen and
like get around it whereas you know if
we turned up just two Muppets that have
been like join the queue and absolutely
not yeah did you ever do a thing with
like Nigella Lawson
no Mary Berry Mary Berry maybe we did
Mary Berry we made pizza with Mary Berry
was that in her Garden or something in
her garden oh cuz when you said that
story of like driving to Italy to get
the van I was like I was watching a I
was watching a cooking show with my mom
like two months ago and I remember that
story so that was you guys it's
literally insane how many people watch
watch the merry very show the amount of
people who watched that show I just
randomly watching it with my mom and it
was like you you guys that was us in the
garden telling the story The Pizza
exactly making a pizza telling the story
Mary Berry is like exactly how he'
wanted to be there was like a moment
where the whole like shooting stopped
stopped happening and she um well she
baked everyone cakes obviously for like
the breaks and there was the shooting
stopped and like went off to have a
cigarette or whatever and she like
completely unironically went into her
garden and like just gathered a bunch of
wild flowers and just like came back and
was like here you go guys here some
flowers it was just like Mary Barry
you're like everything I'd H you would
be and more nice sorry I derailed with
that excitement of like wait a minute I
think I've seen this on TV um so you
completely separate we made this TV show
it did end up featuring on the Food
Network uh I reckon about 27 or 28
people watched it in total including my
family we were never very proud of it I
haven't actually watched the whole thing
in total in my my myself but it did two
things that was amazing for us it it it
opened some doors in Italy and like
allowed us to get into places that we
couldn't otherwise have done and I think
it kind of it gave the business like a
sort of momentum a sort of fake momentum
that meant that like people were kind of
like oh this is coming up this must be
something as opposed to like does that
make sense yeah so I guess like if we
think of you know within within stories
I like to think of sort of takeaway
lessons from people it's like your
brother taking advantage of the industry
he was already in to be like hang on
let's let's have a punt and see what we
can do here yeah which is just you know
some if someone didn't have access to
that industry or didn't know that that
was was a possibility they wouldn't
their brain wouldn't even have thought
that it's it's an option to like I have
no idea what these companies are that
you just mentioned yeah production
companies but but again I I I think for
me the lesson there is send the email to
the person with the spurious connection
yeah that that's the thing for me that
like we've always done and certainly in
the early days we did it like
relentlessly of just like if there's any
reason to like reach out to people just
do it because people always want to help
yeah they always want to tell their
story they always want to like meet
like-minded people who do similar stuff
so like me emailing that boss person who
did not know me I did not know her and
just saying hey you're off to start a
bakery I'm starting another bread
product based business we should
definitely go for a coffee that that's
that's the eny kind like create your own
luck Vibe I guess um and it's just you
know if you shoot enough things you know
throw enough [__] at the wall something
will stick right yeah and so have have
you had any other examples in your life
or the business's life where like a cold
email has been like whoa we didn't
expect that to so so many of those I'm
not going to be able to think of any I
will do eventually but like so many
examples as well where like we'd go and
do an event and you'd get there and my
brother would look at me like what the
hell are we doing here it's raining on a
Tuesday and we're making pizza in a car
par fcking space in Hammer Smith or
something this is depressing and you do
it and you'd be like yeah this is
depressing whatever you do it and then
you know you'd be chat to people there
someone would give you a card and then a
year later you know you've even have
that person back like great to meet you
like come and have a pizza sometime and
then a year later it's like oh I'm
actually like you know so and so's best
mate and I'm you know or I know you know
landlord who's got a sight and he thinks
you'd be great or just these weird
connections that just come from like
building those those actual connections
chat to people and then follow following
up basically um and it's happened to us
over and over again and I think that's
the other thing I never understand about
sort of business as you see on the Telly
is just this whole like sort of
aggressive you know I'll step on your
throat to get to the next level yeah
it's like but that person whose throat
you stepped on is like an opportunity
that you've squashed that will never
ever come back to be an opportunity and
I think we have genuinely I know it
sounds like a cliche but we've genuinely
tried to like never be those guys and
like all you know it's amazing to me how
many times people that you never thought
you'd see again or would never have any
relevance to your business or your
personal life or whatever just reappear
in your life yeah I had had one I mean
it's not hugely business relevant but
like um the manager of swingers where we
swingers you know the crazy golf club we
we were in their first ever popup doing
pizza and the manager of the place the
guy who you know we we kind of gotten
pretty well with and it was all bit
chaotic and but you know we we kind of
worked with him and it was mad and two
days ago like he turned up uh on my
front step in where I lived down near
Brighton uh because he he he was seeing
if anyone needs a gardener it's like
he's there just like randomly there and
you're like oh amazing this is so good
what a great connection and I just I
love those i' hate to think that he
turns up and you open the door and he's
like oh it's you that horrible horrible
person that did that horrible horrible
thing to me yeah yeah I think this I I
often think about this this idea of
serendipity and a lot of like if I think
of all of the different
if I think of all of the different sort
of Step changes we've seen in our
business basically all of them have been
a result of a single a single
conversation with like a random person
that like if I hadn't just sent them a
DM on Twitter that day or if yeah they
didn't happen to have already known like
you know there was a case where I I took
the these two guys' online course on
like writing and like note taking and
stuff and they happen to have seen my
YouTube channel and so I was engaging in
the zoom chat on the like during
lockdown and they were like oh Ali abdal
I recognized that name and then I DMD
them on Zoom there to be like hey let's
hop on a call afterwards hopped on a
call afterwards and that that one call
changed our first product from being
like a I don't know $100,000 product to
like a $3 million product just instantly
in like 10 10 minutes on a zoom call
yeah and my mind just blown it's like
what the hell it's like a
random thing of like this leads to this
leads to this leads to this yeah mental
and particularly in restaurants where
like you know have so many people coming
through and like just making sure you're
like taking the time to like just grab
people and chat to them whether that's
you know team member or
customer or whatever just like always
exciting stuff comes from it always yeah
the other thing that I find surprising
is that within business the world seems
very small yeah like everyone's kind of
knows like knows everyone else in a
weird way yeah and you would think that
all there's all these businesses out
there but actually it's like it's a
fairly small Network it totally is and I
think um I tell that's one absolutely
amazing thing about Hospitality as an
industry like and I don't have a huge
number of other Industries to other than
advertising where worked but like
everyone in Hospitality wants to help
everyone else like I can call up so many
people now and be like hey your
restaurant here how does it do or you
know you've worked with this landlord
what do you think or and we just chat
about everything it's like sort of like
you know mother's meeting type thing
it's it's great and
like I don't think other Industries do
that I think if you work in retail you
don't you know I don't think Curry's are
speaking to M&S to find out what's going
on and whether this site's working for
them and it's just not happening whereas
100% happens in Hospitality so don't
them like is isn't there a sense of like
competition like footfall competition
and stuff like that not really because I
think the general consensus is the more
restaurants there are in a place the
more footfall there'll be is I I think
it's a kind of of the chicken and egg
like the restaurants are first and then
the people come um so you know I've
never or very very rarely encountered I
can't think of anyone the top of my head
someone who's like Kg on this stuff like
everyone on new sites new locations when
a new you know new exciting things
happen happens like baty power station
or whatever like we all chat about like
you know is it working for you what's
your deal that's what happens and I love
that it's like and I think I think it's
basically built from like you know back
to your earlier question like
hospitality is the perfect industry if
you love people if like you get your if
you recharge by like chatting to new
people and like being in busy situations
and just like constantly being like
surrounded by people to chat to
hospitality is that and so everyone who
starts a success Hospitality business is
built that way and therefore they all
want to chat to their their direct
competitors and get point of view from
them and yeah nice okay so you're in
Italy you're going to buy a van in Italy
how did you how did you get the money
for the van Barkley card oh really we
put the whole thing on a barley card how
much was it uh it was just over 10K okay
you can buy a pizza van for 10K uh well
at the time the van itself I think was €
6,900 okay uh I mean the van is so the
big Discovery when we land in Italy so
we we bought the van in re jod Calabria
which is like the tip of the toe just
opposite the water on Sicily um and we
picked it up turned the ignition pulled
out the pulled out the sort of showroom
and realized that this thing had a top
speed of like 20 mil hour yeah like we
genuinely didn't know that until we
pulled out it was like this is the most
ridiculous vehicle we have footage of us
being overtaken up a hill by a jogger
that is how slow the vehicle is uh and
so yeah that kind of very quickly
reframed the trip because it was like
okay so that thing that drive that we
thought we could do in an hour and a
half not going to happen um the way to
work out the speed of an app is to take
the average on Google of the car time
and the walk time nice that's that's the
midp point is the the speed of your
actual vehicle okay so you pay 10K you
get this van you trundle it up back to
the UK trundle it up back to the UK via
loads of pizza stops we we went and made
mozzarella we learned about tomatoes we
but I mean the big moment is when went
to Naples so again we didn't really know
that neapolis and pizza was kind of the
big the big one and that's where it all
started but we went to Naples we had a
pizza in Dam and we were just like how
have I lived for 27 28 years and not had
this before Y and it didn't really exist
in London at that time there was Frank
and maner just starting out and it was
just phenomenal it had one in Brixton
and one in um Chic I think at that time
uh and there was another Pizzeria called
Atlantica Pizzeria and there was one in
Clapham called Don margar
that was kind of it for neapolitan pizza
at that time um so we just hadn't tried
it and we just fell in love with it and
we were like this is what we want to
recreate what's special about neapolis
and pizza so it has this kind of like I
guess it's particularly in the UK the of
Famous Pizza words are like thin and
crispy that's what people want but
Neapolitan is very much like it's kind
of doughy and bready and like floppy oh
and you is that is that like the style
of your pizza yeah like you almost want
to fold it you fold it got like
structure type Pizza which is like very
yeah you could pick up a triangle and it
would be a triangle this is like like
yeah that sort of thing so it's kind of
it's a very different thing you know
everyone always jokes about eat people
who eat pizza with a knife and fork in
the UK but actually go to Naples loads
of people eat pizza with a knife and
fork because it's the way to do it so um
yeah we discovered neapolitan pizza that
style and it is a very specific style
happens to be the like birthplace of
pizza as well uh and yeah we have never
looked back really okay so you come back
to the UK and then you've got one
one van yeah so how does how does
business start the business plan was we
would uh plan quote unquote uh was we
would do events so we'd go and do like
weddings you know funerals B Mitzvah
whatever whatever you whatever event
you've got will turn up and make pizza
for a degree price we quickly real
realized that a it's really hard to
build a name to yourself that way
because kind of need a place that people
can go and try if you're gonna get
people excited about a product they've
got to be able to go and try it y off
their own steam so that that was a no no
and second it's just it's just so
incredibly stressful like being
responsible like the most important day
in your life you know if you're going to
cat to someone's wedding the stress
factor of like getting that wrong or
whatever is is just too high to deal
with yeah so we very quickly moved away
from that and we're like no we want to
Market St on a place where you can come
and come and actually buy it so we
started emailing all the councilors to
say like you know do you have a pitch
there was probably about seven or eight
like really great food markets in London
emailed all of them constantly just
heard about saying no we have no space
there's a waiting list as long as they
arm it just you know most of them were
like just don't bother joining the list
cuz you know it's going to be decades oh
wow and then um so then we were like
well this just can't be right because
we're going to these markets and they're
not full so we basically started going
down to the markets taking pictures of
us standing in empty spaces Y and
emailing accounts be like we stood in
this space from 11:00 a.m. till 400 p.m.
for 5 days in a row no one came yeah how
can you possibly tell me your Market is
full and I think we basically just like
hammered them so much until they just
eventually like it would be easier to
just give them the pitch than it would
to so yeah eventually the First Council
to give up was Westminster they gave us
a pitch on Barrack Street Market we paid
£10 a day for our yeah it was amazing oh
that's reasonable little little parking
spot on the market and we could trade
there from uh 11: till well we could
trade there from 9: obviously no one
wants piz for N9 until uh I think you
could trade till 5 so we basically went
and did lunch service every day that's
only1 pound a day10 pound a day is that
normal or is that surprisingly cheap uh
it's still the same and it's kind of
like that classic like you know it's
kind of it was a agreed decades and
decades ago and they can't change it and
there are people there who trade there
every day whose grandparents traded
there at the same rate I mean to be
clear the10 p a day gives you a lovely
pitch but like zero infrastructure so
when we were there you got you know you
had no electricity nowhere to store in a
thing so you had to literally drive a
van into Soho unload set up the van uh
and then drive you know drive it away
again find someone to part that van come
back set up the store so it was not you
know it was not Rosie we basically set
about the first month was like how do we
make this easier yeah because driving a
van in every day especially Soho is just
a living nightmare so we made friends
with the uh landlord of the pub which
called the endurance on baric Street uh
convinced him to let us uh rent his
basement 50 a week which we did so we
made the dough started making the dough
in that basement then we started to
slowly but surely convince the guys the
fruit and FEG guys which is at the time
the market was mostly fruit and FEG guys
um we convinced them that we were like
not bad people I think they were just
very suspicious of us turning up trying
to I they called us The Apprentice for a
long time because we were like running
around like headless chickens trying to
let do anything we convinced them that
we were like a Force for good they they
then let rented us their fridge space in
the lock up that they had there uh then
I convinced my old advertising agency to
let us let us park the van underneath
their agency in a car parking space
which is now the Soho hotel and slowly
over the first six months we built this
like infrastructure around the business
there's a lot of convincing a lot of
convincing unusual cuz I'm so used to
online businesses and stuff where you
literally don't have to speak to anyone
yeah this is very like oh yeah you're
out there chatting to the pub guy
chatting to the fruit and vegg people
chatting to the yeah and I think you
know again love it that's absolutely me
and my brother's thing but it is also it
comes with you know all of the kind of
human uh you know failings and just sort
of what's the word you know inaccuracies
I guess of like you know suddenly the
pub landlord on one day is like actually
I've changed my mind you're out you've
got to be out by 4M I've loaded all your
stuff onto the street and you've got to
go and like reconvince him that it's
actually okay and uh so you know there's
that stuff there's you know just just
that it's never fixed it's never like
and I think that's the one thing about
Hospitality but particularly street food
the number one asset you can have is
resilience yeah just like those little
things that change at the last last
minute just being able to deal with
it if we take a day a random day in
those in those first six months yeah
compare it to a day in your life as like
working in corporate what's the
contrast the well the main the main
contrast for me are just were two like
one you have no real context of the kind
of financial particularly in advertising
because it's all you know and I was
Junior anyway but like you have no
feeling you're really earning a a wage
you're just kind of doing something and
at the end you get this packet this pay
packet that just land you know on the
last Friday of the month a pay packet
arrives but you don't really link the
two I found it's just like you're doing
loads of stuff and it's all happening
and then pay packet arrives but then the
next day you're just doing the stuff
again whereas when you're running your
own
thing you're really kind of like
constantly doing the sums of your head
of like well if we did that and that's a
day of the month is that going to you
know deliver enough to get to get us to
that next line that next Finish Line so
that constant like weighing up of like
what you're putting your time into and
your energy into yeah and is it going to
pay which you just don't I think do in a
corporate life I mean I didn't anyway um
but the second one and probably the
bigger one is just that you know if you
work in a big corporate office there's
someone's call to fix anything that's
not your exact responsibility so it's
like this thing is broken that thing's
gone wrong I need a point of view on
that you know you send the email out and
you wait for that response to come back
and then you kind of funnel it into the
next part the thing you kind of you've
constantly got the support network
around you start your own business you
have no support network whatsoever
everything is you if something's broken
you've got to fix it with a spanner it's
you if uh you know you've lost you you
know put your cash down someone's robbed
it that's your problem if you've made
the dough incorrectly that's your
problem the van's broken down that's
your problem if it rains it's your
problem everything's your problem
which I don't know I guess some people
get a kick out of that because they're
like cool well I'm I'm I'm ready to
solve those problems bring it on and I'm
feeling like I'm a capable person and
that's exciting and I guess you know
that kind of like changes as good of a
rest it changes as good as a rest type
feeling of like never a d day because
you just don't know what's going to
happen um whereas other people obviously
are like no this is my skill set why in
God's name would I try and fix a van or
make dough if my skill set is only in
selling or mending computers or the law
um and I think you know that undoubtedly
that makes sense right logically if
you're really good at the law your time
is not well spent fixing Vans and making
dough you're never going to be
financially your best possible better to
apply yourself to the law and make that
work for you but I guess no one
logically starts a business I don't know
maybe they do I think they probably
that's probably a bit too much of a
sweeping statement No One logically
starts a restaurant business that's for
sure sure um what would you say to
people who might be thinking you know
what I want to quit my job to start a
business because I want more free time
h i mean there is no such thing as free
time everything is a blur like calendars
you know the little blocks you get in
calendars like you know like 11 10 till
11 this will happen it's just nonsense
it's all just gray everything's the same
but I I I guess you know another way to
look at it is like that's all it's
whether you see that as all free time or
all work that that's the fundamental
dichotomy there of like if you see
having no 10 to 11: a.m. meetings and no
places have to be at certain times as
freeing then start your own business and
you'll absolutely love it because it's
just constantly like that whereas if you
see that as like I I I cannot you know I
need to know when I'm doing X and when
I'm doing y then you're never going to
you know it doesn't work like that it's
just constantly changing yeah and to
what extent can you clock off at like
5:00 p.m. 600 p.m. kind of thing when
you have a business do you know what
increasingly I can now I I could clock
off and I could go you know what I'm not
going to do that and I'm trying to be
better at
it but unfortunately I think it's just
it always is there you know you'll be
sitting there clocked off watching
something on telly and something come
like oh that's that's cool I wonder if
we could try that in the pizzeria or
like oh you see an advert for something
you're like oh that's interesting that
they've said it you know said it that
way I wonder how that affects us or you
know you you you do just never ever ever
switch off especially when you've got a
phone next to you and you can
immediately Google it and then you're
off then you're off then you're off down
the rabbit hole again Y and my wife
rightly is just livid about that she's
like you can't do it like you've got to
stop like if you don't stop um and I
find if I lie you know if I lie in bed
at night and I'm not listening to a
podcast or something my brain just
racing and like oh what about if we did
that and you know and I
think a blessing in a curse it's nice to
have a sort of thing that drives you
forward in many ways and like gives you
gives you ways to like approach stuff
and it's nice to have a point review on
things that you know how could I make
that work for me but yeah it's also it
must also be lovely and I definitely do
dream about this to be like I tell you
when I most dream about it it's exactly
about now when you clock out of the
office uh Friday bank holiday yeah and
you like you walk out at 4: because it's
Friday and everyone's like whatever just
go home you go home you're like I
literally have nothing to worry about
now until Tuesday that never happens
that never ever ever happens to me um
because restaurants particularly again
they never stop I go to bed at 10
o'clock at night
you know the guys is still out there
guys and girls are still out there doing
incredible things for pizza pilgrims so
you know Sunday afternoon watching the
football yep petb is still open yeah and
so like it is a weird feeling it
like you know it just it just it's never
you know and the worst thing you can do
to a restaurant quite generally is stop
like the momentum we closed basically
twice a year for like a full team party
and we close all the restaurants
guarantee the next day is when you have
the most like mechanical issues the most
like delivery problems because if if the
flywheel stops yep it You' got you know
it really takes a lot to get it going
again um and I guess you know if you
plot my particular curve involved in
that at the beginning it was just us and
we were very much Hands-On with every
single thing so you never had these like
rug pull moments because you were just
there I mean they happened but they kind
of happened live and you were just
dealing with it then you had the bit
where you know we weren't necessarily in
the restaurants at 9 o'cl at night but
you'd be there trying to switch off and
you get the call being like this has
blown up or that thing's gone wrong or
someone's just coming and tried to mug
us or and there that was my worst time
because then I would just be like right
you know you're trying to trying to you
know calm and suddenly you've got to
like drop everything and rush off and
fix some like much bigger problem um and
I guess you know we're lucky now and
that like we have grown we have got like
you know really amazing teams and we've
got a fantastic managing director and
he's got op director below him and then
you know head of operations Ops managers
each store has a manager an assistant
manager like it has to be pretty nuclear
for it to get to me now yeah but that
said I always want to know it always
read the reports you know it's if
something does go wrong it's like how
can we be better next time how can we
stop it happening but that middle bit
where you don't have the management but
you do have the kind of freedom I
actually found the
worst yeah the feeling of like having
having your own business so like my my
girlfriend has recently quit her day job
go fulltime on her business and she's
like you know gets to 11:00 p.m. and
she's like oh but I've just had a moment
of inspiration where I feel so excited
about this thing and like back in the
day when she had the day job she was
always being like hey Ellie why are you
working at 11:00 p.m. come on like you
know like work life balance and all this
kind of stuff and and now she gets it
and I'm like oh yeah and back in the day
we she used to be like you know when
we're on holiday like you know why are
you working all the time and now she's
like man I don't have time to work
during during normal times like oh we
can do so much work on holiday and I'm
like yes there you go you see this just
the the whole like psychology changes I
guess when it's your thing 100 now
there's like there's like a really
powerful reason to work on it massively
and you know I think the obvious again
very obvious cliche but the obvious
connection there is is kids you see
people with kids you're like oh I would
never do it that way or like you know I
could handle that whatever and then when
you have kids of your own you're like oh
right okay this is this is it this is
what it's all about and it does just
never stop we have a question here from
Asma from our telegram community would
you recommend working full-time or
part-time as you start your business so
that you have a stable income already or
would you recommend that one invests all
of their time into their
startup I personally found
it beneficial to to to to test it more
and like you know not not throw
everything out and go like I'm out done
so we did quit we did go and do this
trip we did build the business but in
the very very early days it was like
look this is crazy we're not going to be
able to both both do this so I I got I
came back I quit my job in advertising
advertising Adidas and got a job
advertising St of stairlifts uh and
started doing that like in parallel and
I guess we we when we started out did a
lot of testing of like right here's you
know we want to start a pizza business
let's get 50 mates around for dinner
party and do pizza and see how that goes
and if that's good and we enjoy it and
we kind of then you can kind of go right
what's the next thing the next thing in
our case was let's go to my old
advertising agency and park up outside
and do pizza for lunch for them and see
how they get on and then the next thing
is like let's go and do a one night
event and like you know pay 100 quid and
do and I think that is the way to do it
obviously it depends what your business
is but like you've got you've got to my
mind like doing some basic basic testing
even if it's like I'm going to take a
week holiday and go and just do this for
a week yeah is a great way to do it you
don't need to throw the baby out of the
bath water yeah that's very much my view
of it as well I think there are some
businesses where you don't have that
option but like Broly you know I I think
actually having a job and doing doing
the thing doing the business on the side
forces you to prioritize yeah cuz I
found that two years into two years
after I was I did the doctor stuff and
suddenly I had spare time my output
reduced in terms of number of videos we
were making cuz I spend all spending all
my time doing the [__] that I just
didn't have time to do back in the day
and I was like well I can now reply to
all these emails and like hop on calls
with all these people who want to hop on
calls in the end and it's like before I
know it my entire calendar is booked up
with like unpr I discovered and I'm like
oh my God I can just give a link out
it's like bloody hell Zoom calls all day
oh [__] like and it took about a year to
realize that oh back when I was doing
this as a side hustle I intuitively
prioritized the most important things
and ignored everything else yeah now I
need to actively prioritize the most
important things and ignore everything
else which requires figuring out what's
the goal what are the metrics that
matter what is the needle moving stuff
what's the 8020 and like desperately
trying to ignore all the other
opportunities that are coming my way
yeah and I think that that I mean that's
exactly you know classic thing of like
you know you want something done ask
someone busy type thing and I think I
think that's exactly right I think we
had a that sort of similar inflection
point of like because we started out
with like no plan and no you know we
just knew we need we had this thing and
we needed to like get it out there and
grow it so we we started out just doing
everything it was like yes to everything
which is why we ended up in car parking
spaces in Hammer Smith and all that kind
of stuff but but it always it always led
to something and it was like the right
thing to do I believe to just like throw
yourself into everything and like but
you're right very quickly that becomes
overwhelming very quickly you are doing
stuff that's like you know what we could
have been better off doing this or that
or the other and I think once you kind
of someone want talk to me about this
analogy of like you're pushing a ball up
a hill and then you go over the you go
you go onto the downhill bit once you've
kind of got to a certain level and then
your job is to like direct the ball
rather than like push the ball oh yeah
that's nice and I think I think that
that was an inflection point that I
think we kind of wrestle with a bit
because I was still very much like no
we're still going up the hill and I
think my brother was like we're over the
hill we need to stop saying yes to the
stuff at the edge and just focus on the
pizzeria or you know making the product
better or whatever it is um and so yeah
I think I think we still though we still
always get our heads turned by like
shiny new stuff it's always like oh but
that would be wouldn't it be cool to do
you know go and do Glen Bri and I think
the business now looks at us like what
like why would we do glassen B like we
know we're not going to make any money
it's going to be super stressful we
haven't got you know we have to drag
people out the pizzeria so we call loads
of stress for people who aren't even at
Glen Bri because they're all their
teammates are in a field with you and no
one you're not going to get any
publicity about it really I just I don't
get it and we're just like oh but you
know it's cool to do yeah and like I
think you know and I kind of like that
because I think you know another I think
mine and my brother's role when now we
know we've always been Founders who've
never been CEOs or whatever but like I
think our role kind of is to like throw
in that stuff that's like the grown-ups
all go like that makes no literally no
sense why would we do that um and you
know 90% of the time they're right and
we don't do it but actually sometimes
I'm like no no we really do actually
think this will move the D forward and
like we will so know quite recently
we've just done our 10th birthday and we
were like we need to go and like revisit
you know reestablish the pilgrimage
thing it's such a big part of our brand
and we need to like reinvigorate our
menu we've got to be staying ahead of
everyone else and we basically came up
with this idea of we need another
ridiculous vehicle to do it in so we we
got veser and we work with this amazing
company to build a side car that turned
into a pizzeria like a Transformer oh
and so we have the world's first veser
pizzeria wow and then we drove that to
Naples and we drove it around Naples for
10 days making 10 films about new menu
items and like we had this incredible
full circle moment where we'd first ever
tasted Pizza in Dam super revered temper
of Pizza in Naples they allowed us to
come into Dem and do a popup in their
restaurant take it over for a whole
night put pizza [__] the door and was
like that's 10 years of us like knowing
those guys and working with the Naples
Community and like building
relationships and it's amazing it's an
amazing thing to done but like I guess
when we first proposed this idea
everyone was like this is this is
nonsense like we definitely shouldn't do
this and actually it's been a it's been
a great way to reestablish a business
the amount of the amount of sort of
coverage we've got from it has been
great nice okay so you're in this market
for the1 pound a day you got the pizza
yeah what are what's what's like the
daily profit and loss of the business
when you're when you're a pizza Food Van
in in a market so we sold pizza for 5
quid yeah uh so5 pound of pizza they was
quite a bit smaller probably than the
ones we make now but um yeah5 pound for
margarita and we a great day would be500
didn't take cards okay so so didn't take
card so £500 in in cash 100 pizzas 100
pizzas that would be a good day I think
I'll record date ever was like 120
pieces okay on that market store yeah
then you'd go and do something like
British summertime yeah and you could
you could happily do 800 pieces in a day
ah and suddenly and you're probably
charging a little bit more because it's
a festival so that's when you're
starting to make like real money yeah
but you know again like so SC it's such
a weird thing like no cards so you're
literally at the end of the day you're
there with a box of cash why why didn't
you take cards because it was 2012 there
was no way to take cards on a market
wasn't a thing didn't exist I zle and
all
that but no I mean it didn't exist in
2012 yeah did not exist in 2014 I
started using that for some stuff yeah
but like yeah 2012 was like old school
it's proper old school so like get like
a world pay Enterprise account or some
[__] like that to accept cards genuinely
one of our biggest challenges every day
was what how much change we had really
like did we have enough like literally
coins and I still I still [__] hate
change to this day I never have cash I
never because I just remember the trauma
of dealing with cash and then I remember
in 2013 so vividly because we'd started
the business on a Barkley card I emailed
Barkley card and said hey we're opening
a pizzeria next month um I [__] hate
cash can we just make it completely
cashless can we be the UK's first
cashless restaurant and this was in 2013
and we had a meeting in their big tall
tower in I think it was in Canary wolf
or something like that um and they were
up for it and then we got over ruled by
all of our investors they were like this
is nonsense like yeah why they were like
you can't you can't run a restaurant and
turn people away if they only have cash
and I was like we absolutely can and
they were like no no you can't can't do
that it's too risky got overruled and I
didn't win that argument I think I
basically had that argument once a year
every year for seven or eight years and
only the first time I won it was Co wow
yeah okay and it's like it makes no cash
makes no sense it's like it's you have
to ensure you know you have people
walking out of your restaurants after
you know a busy weekend you get a young
guy or girl walking to the bank with
like thousands of pounds strapped to
their back through Soho I'm like it's
just not safe for that person straight
straight off you have to pay more for
the insurance it's just it's slower it's
a faf you got to have change it's got to
be stored on site the whole thing is
just a nightmare it's like cards are
just like dreamy so yeah all of our
pizzas now are cashless finally thank
goodness so first six months you're in
in the market toall yeah so that's 2013
2012 March 2012 we sold our first pizza
nice and then how does the business grow
over the next like few years like what
was the what were the big so we started
that Markus st500 was a good day um uh
and you know we we basically do the
markting store for lunch at least four
days mostly we do it at least four days
a week sorry so500 is a good day of
which how much is profit like what are
the margins on a business like this I
think like quite honestly we were
investing all of our profit in like
things in like doing other stuff so you
go and do a festival they take a pitch
fee so you guys aren't making any money
no personally I think we we took a100
each a week wow okay that was that was
the money we were making so how did you
sustain yourselves during that period uh
I was very lucky that my wife uh had a a
job I mean she worked also for an
advertising it certainly wasn't like an
amazing you know High salary or anything
but that was you know that was a huge
help she wasn't my wife at time she was
my girlfriend then my f so I was yeah uh
we were we boyfriend and girlfriend I
had a stable job then we got engaged and
then about about a week later I was like
I think I'm going to quit my job and
start a stupid Pizza thing how did her
family feel about this uh I think they
were confused slash um yeah again more
eyebrow raises more like you sure this
is the right thing yeah um I think just
on that point and I'd like to make this
point I feel so so strongly that it is
the right thing I think you know if
you're if you have that thing in you
whatever that is to want start a
business the longer you wait thinking
that you're getting gaining invaluable
experience the more your life is like
crystallizing into a thing and you have
a mortgage and you have you know kids
maybe and you have all these things that
actually do make the risk you're taking
a bigger risk and I just think you know
that this idea of like oh you know you I
just think you've got to go for it early
like if you're going to do it do it as
early as you possibly can that's not say
you can't do it later and obviously if
you've got a great job and youve built
up a big nest egg and that that's a
whole different conversation
but I I don't know I it annoys me that
we don't encourage people straight after
their ear levels definitely straight
after University to to to go and have a
crack or something I know you know
you've got to have the money but we we
didn't we put on a credit card yeah like
I think having a crack then is the best
way because I just don't I think the
more you kind of learn what you think is
the right way to do something the more
more you know when the road's not that
and you have to deviate yeah you don't
deviate you just go no but I really
believe that this is the way to do it
yes I know that some people then create
Facebook and that's fine I get that but
most people don't most people have their
you know their set worldview they set
out into the market the market tells
them you're kind of 60% of the way there
but it's actually here and this you know
the more if you've done it for 10 years
and you're super set in your ways I
don't think you I think you're harder to
deviate yeah oh by the way in case you
have not yet heard my book is about to
come out it's called Feelgood
productivity how to do more what matters
to you and it's a book that I've been
working on for the last 3 years now it's
being published at the end of December
2023 but pre-orders are actually
available and I know people don't like
pre-ordering the book but if you do
pre-order the book and you email me your
receipt you will get completely free
access to a live exclusive event that
I'm hosting in the first weekend of
January of 2024 and this is a live
online Workshop all about annual
planning goal setting and reflection and
so I'm going to be facilitating a group
with hopefully hundreds of people from
all around the world and we're going to
be going through how to figure out what
to do with our life and how to turn that
into goals for the year and how to build
systems and how to be consistent with
stuff and how to make sure that we are
enjoying the journey along the way that
is purely exclusively available for
people who pre-order the book as a thank
you for our little community so if you
want to check it out you can check out
the book you can maybe consider
pre-ordering it the link will be down in
the video description one of the things
I think i' I've heard you talk about
before is Founders naivity yeah yeah
yeah what what do you mean by that I I
just think so many things that we have
in our business that I love about our
business still were came to pass because
we'd never worked in restaurants before
we'd worked behind the bar in our
parents Pub but we'd never like running
a big you know worked in a big
restaurant company and just the way you
know way the way you treat the team how
you kind of you know obviously famously
restaurants are you know hard hours long
hours we were always like no one works
more than these hours if you work more
than your contracted hours is a problem
not not a benefit you know giving
splitting tips between chefs in front of
house at the time it was like no no the
front of house take all the tips
sometimes they give some to the chefs
and I'm like well what so I've gone in
I've had a nice Pizza leave a tip and
the chef sees none of that it's like
yeah that's what happens and I'm like
that's nonsense so we changed that and
we split it 5050 and we still do yeah
and little things like that I think and
the more you kind of you know have
experience in Industry the more you just
kind of follow the her and I think and
that's to me not the definition of
starting your own thing but question
from Patrick from our my deep diver
telegram Community which is what are the
key things that you wished you knew
before opening a food food
business I wish I knew I guess quite
honestly more about the financial bit
like I knew nothing about a p&l nothing
about like I've never even heard of a
p&l had no kind of concept of like vat
or like and I
think we tried to sort of plot some
stuff out but I did it so fundamentally
wrong
and the fact is that like running
particularly a restaurant business
understanding the numbers helps you
understand the business and actually
looking at the
numbers uh from afar you can tell a
business that's like a happy business or
a sad business just by looking at like
the productivity for example so that
their labor percentage how much how much
money they're taking as a restaurant how
much they're spending on labor y you can
tell which ones are teams that are
struggling or like not delivering at the
right productivity level or maybe a new
team or versus the ones that are like
absolutely flying setting their ways and
they're the ones who are happy because
they they everyone knows what they're
doing everyone's got their role they've
got the tools to do the job well
everything's flying and you can see that
and I think you know we just didn't know
anything about numbers at all I'm quite
a numbers guy like I did you know lots
of mass a levels I did psychology at Uni
which was all statistics and stuff and
so like kind of really delved into that
but we kind of we spent a long time like
just learning it and then and then
Sheltering everyone from it because we
were like well no one wants to know the
numbers because it's just the boring bit
like the fun bit is running the
restaurant having fun and like creating
a party atmosphere but the managers
definitely don't want to see this so
we'll we'll keep that away from them let
them run the party and actually that's
so not true like numbers just free
everyone up to know like what success
looks like I think you I think you often
think um as a Founder I guess that like
a blank sheet of paper is everyone's
dream of like why don't you just go and
do it your way and you know will
absolutely be here to support you but
like here you know just go go for your
life it's your Pizzeria and actually 90%
of people don't want that at the very
least they want some lines on the paper
and they want you know maybe a couple of
headers of like how do you fill this
paper out and I think we started the
business thinking that everyone loved
the blank bit of paper and what you've
absolutely got to do is make sure there
is definitely blank space for be able to
fill but and obviously everyone's
different but the vast majority w some
kind of framework to work in that's so
true like this is a big realization I've
had in the last like 12 months as well
where I thought like everyone in my team
wants the same autonomy that I do and so
it's like great what what that looks
like is me not giving them Direction
because they can they can obviously make
it up and they prefer it and then
literally everyone on team is like no
like we like autonomy but we also like
having a direction and we like knowing
what success looks like to you because
like fundamentally if it's not like
successful
like similarly like in the last six
months various people in the team we've
we've been saying to the team that you
know we've got someone in charge of our
YouTube channel and the podcast and
social media and stuff and we're like
we're saying to them we want you guys to
be the sort of the CEOs of your own
departments and then one like an
immediate question is like cool what's
the budget and we're like huh that's a
good question yeah um I don't know like
unlimited and like well it's not
unlimited because like like you know if
we spent 2 million on this thing you'd
probably have a problem with it like
yeah so what's a budget I'm like okay
yeah this is actually us worth us
sitting down and figuring out yeah and
now people have a budget now they get it
they're like okay I've got 100K to play
with to be able to do all this this
stuff yeah but what you so it's so
interesting cuz I for years hate budgets
and I went in my kind of business Mentor
person not Mentor but like someone who I
look up to is John timson if you had
John timson so he runs he was he used to
run his son now runs it timson uh like
the timson Sho shops have you come
across the timson test no what's that
the timson test is like a from the
timson like shops yeah it's like uh like
10 questions that every um manager
should be able to answer about their
employees I've not seen this oh it's
really interesting so my CEO coach uses
the timson test with like the picture of
the little timson like Shoe Shop thing
it's like you know uh how many kids do
they have what are the names of the kids
when's their birthday what's their
favorite blah blah blah that 100% a
Johnson thing and I've not heard it test
but like he his whole thing is um he
calls it upside down management so he's
like the most important person in your
business is the person serving the
customer and they should have as much
autonomy as they need to do that job y
uh and and to be able to like make the
customer happy so I think every employee
in timson to spend 500 pound of company
money to write a customer complaint
without any kind of approval process uh
they have no Central epos so let every
store the manager knows how many key
fobs you need to order that week how
many they sold last week they have a
budget um the reason I got into this is
the budget thing they have a budget in
the store of like this is your sales
Target for the week and everything above
that they get a third of oh nice so like
you know this is what you got to do but
if you beat it you can have a big chunk
of it yeah nice um but he was so I went
out to meet him weirdly my grandmother
decorated a house for him once in ch so
she's like oh yeah I've met John timson
send an email somehow we agreed to let
us go up me and my brother for a day and
chat to him yeah just like such an
inspirational guy but um he was like I
hate budgets they're nonsense you write
down a number on the 1st of January and
you're telling me that like the the 31st
of December that you'd have been right
and that it's he's I literally do a
budget because I have to because Bank
make me but I make no one stick to it I
want I I want to know I want to know I
want people to just sort of feel it I
guess and like you know I don't want
anyone to be like punished for a number
that I wrote down on the 1 of January
but also don't want to hold anyone back
because I feel like if you hit that
finish line and you're done that changes
your changes your energy a bit um
whether he's right or wrong on the whole
no budget thing but I guess in your
example you know people do want to know
what the number is and I would say the
best you know the best work that we've
ever done like creatively or you know
that's moved the business forward was
always done on a shoe string rather than
like with a massive pile of money behind
it yeah but you wouldn't if if the
budget's 100 Grand and some like
absolute Game Changer of an opportunity
comes along and it's 200 Grand yeah you
wouldn't want to like oh well this isn't
going you we'll ignore that because it's
never going to work you want to be like
this was my resistance to budget because
I was like guys like think think more
about like p&l like if if you know for
example yeah we we get x amount of
sponsorship dollars per YouTube video we
know that that's like what we get per
YouTube video and therefore like almost
anything to make YouTube videos better
we can justify because of the absurd
amount of um but then yeah it's like I
think it's it's useful for for the team
to know it's like it's 100K rather than
a million for example yeah but also that
that 100K is like actually fairly
malleable yeah I think that's the
important thing is known it's malleable
and we've you know as we grown we've had
to put in more budgets particularly for
different departments and I'm always
like it's it's a guide It's a guide It's
not like the target it's not you know if
you spend more than it it's a problem if
you spend less than it you're going to
get a on the back it's just a guide but
yeah you want people to go like oh but
this is outside the budget but it' be
amazing and take that kind of attitude
so Pizza pilgrims now has been going on
for 10 years um years what's the what
are the stats of the business these days
if you don't mind sharing like Revenue
margins that sort of thing yeah so we're
we're we're 24 pizzas um which uh yeah
is more than I could have imagined at
when we had our little market stall 24
pizz areas uh we employe just over 500
people 500 yeah hell which is madness
absolute Madness we had our staff party
uh last week actually our summer party
and yeah that's the that's when you
realize it the most when you see how
much does it cost to do a party for 500
people uh it costs a lot of money uh
it's do you know what it costs less
because because of the industry we're in
like a lot we did it actually with our
good friends at Camden Brewery oh um and
they paid for all the beer yeah so like
you know that that's a big chunk of it
um but but no it's it's but it's it's
great it's you know it it's good to do
that stuff what's interesting sorry I
keep going off on weird tangents but
like young young people are different to
us and I'm not saying you're also a
young person I'm very much middle-aged
I'm 40 now and like they don't you know
where is kind of slightly going out and
having a lot of drinks and that was kind
of like the that was that was the
definition of a good time like kind of
like getting a bit mashed up that's not
that's not what wants right now it's
like there's a whole thing around like
do young people really want a party or
do they would they prefer to just have a
day off and I don't know part one half
of me it's like quite sad we've got
we've got to work really hard you know
in our industry we are about you know
showing people a good time and going out
and that kind of thing and so I think
you know I think people work in that
industry do want to party and they do
want to they do want to kind of engage
with their peers and it's great seeing
like you knowly people move around
different piz ofers and like seeing
those other connections re reestablish
and stuff I I love it but I guess it's I
guess the point I'm trying to make is
the danger is that because I love it
does that mean that they love it and
you've got to be constantly aware of
like is that actually the best thing you
know with that chunk of money whatever
it is is that the best thing you can do
for your team or actually would they
prefer to do something more wholesome or
would they prefer to literally just have
a day off or what is it so you've got to
kind of constantly work on that stuff
but yeah 500 people uh you know with
they're incredible to see them all in
one place uh we we've just finished our
year year end end of um June and I think
turnover of 27 million net of vat and
with an ebit D of about
2.4 uh so like oh okay
interesting so 27 million top like like
Revenue basically yeah after you paid V
yeah and then he do like your operating
profit kind of yeah operating profit
exactly of 2.4 million
yeah that's 10 10%
is uh 10% is is kind of uh a sort of
Target for restaurants but it depends
what you're doing right we we always
well number of things we've always
reinvested all of our profit back in
we've never really taken we've never
ever taken a dividend or anything like
that so you know we're very much like
putting it back into grow yeah and I
think we've always really wanted to grow
at the right rate y the endless debate
we have with our board is about the head
office percentage
cost so you have so you have a pizzer
rear yeah if you take one if you got 24
Pizza rear take
one you know a standard Pizza Ria might
take let's say they might take 30 to 40K
a week they might take as in like that
would be a revenue okay sure so that's
what like 1.5 to two million Revenue uh
and you would hope that you would
convert that 20% some of ours convert
higher than that some convert lower into
ebit into ebitda okay so you've got your
your um two million at 20% would be 400
4 400 e uh and then obviously that all
goes into a big part and then you have
your central overhead which is your head
office that obviously is not none of
them are Revenue generating essentially
so there are people who are like
supporting making sure that those
businesses work really well so that be
marketing
or HR HR operations also sits in there
so our operations team would have you
know our managing Partners as they're
called would have five pizz that they're
responsible for okay they their cost
would sit in head office rather than in
that pizz
um uh anyway so the the big debate is
what
percentage of your Revenue you're
spending on your head office so let's if
it was 10% if your revenue is 27 million
you'd be spending 2.7 million on your
head office sure and from my point of
view I'm like I want to grow right I
want to grow great I want to make sure
business with meat on the bones that
we're making the right decisions you
know we've just applied for a b Corp
we're on our 2030 um
Journey you know Net Zero Journey all
that you know I want to make sure that
the teams are supported that we have the
right training in place that yeah doing
all that stuff and that cost a lot of
money yeah all of that stuff and
therefore your obviously your ebit Dar
percentage is reduced yeah whereas you
could absolutely run that business on a
much much smaller overhead Y and you
could make a lot more money in an annual
basis but I I would suggest that you
know your business will be at the best
maintaining and at worst probably
degrading yeah and so it's how do you we
we've always been like it's a long game
we lit remember when we were carrying
gas bottles above our head on the market
we'd be like it's a long game yeah
everything's about like how do we how do
we shoot forward rather than like do
best now um so it's kind of it's kind of
like so the point I'm making is that
obviously we're blown away by where the
business has got to but it's all about
reinvesting into the future and also
making sure that we're doing it the
right way and we're not like breaking
people or pushing people too hard or
making it not enjoyable because at that
point it's like what's the point yeah
like you know you start a business
because you want you want something
that's better than the corporate job
yeah exactly and I you're not having fun
along the way then if you're not
enjoying it like what is the actual
point um and so yeah we've always tried
to do that that right and we've
definitely made a lot of mistakes but
broadly I think you know we've we've I
don't think we've kind of done wrong by
anyone along the way or tried to kind of
exploit anyone or you know do thing you
we we we've tried to do it what I would
call the right way whether we always
have I let other people decide I guess
and so I'm curious about this this
bottom line actually so so Top Line and
bottom line numbers um to what was the
what's the growth graph looked like over
time has it been like exponential or has
it been like linear or like has it been
Upsy down uh well it's got a sort of uh
it's got sort of coid shaped hole in it
which um doesn't really help but uh do
you know what it's been very slow and I
think what well I would it's been
exponential but not
I don't know it's not kind of curving
away to Infinity sort of like it's sort
of exponential and then it's sort of
plateaued sort of I don't know what
you'd call that yeah exponential to to
Plateau I don't know so it's definitely
sped up but we've never kind of like
carried on the speeding up sure um but I
think you know what always surprises me
about you know people who start a
successful business particularly a
restaurant business where like every
site is so different and so like
completely unique in its location and
challenges and stuff people open one
really success uccessful site and
they're like this is going really well
really enjoying this like really good
you know I'm on the ground a lot blah
blah blah blah and then their next step
is like cool I'm going to go and do four
more next year and I'm like what like
even weirder than that are the ones when
people open one it's not going well and
they're like my solution to that is open
another one yeah I'm like I I do not I
literally do understand yeah like we
were always like get you know get one I
guess our problem was we wanted to make
it perfect so like we were like get this
one absolutely singing We were never
ready to do the next thing and we had to
be pushed to be like guys you're on
marginal gains now you need to move on
to the next one so we did one in August
2013 we didn't want to do another one at
all we got approached with this kind of
insane offer that we wanted to turn down
which to open in cabby Street in kingley
court and we were like just don't think
a TI right time anyway we basically got
pushed into it pretty much the only time
I think our investors are like you
should definitely not not miss this
opportunity uh so we did do that that
was the second one but we didn't do
another one after that for 18 months so
you're already at you you know almost
three years to do three yeah uh and then
and then I think it was another year to
do the fourth so like it took us five
years to open five yeah and we're now at
24 so you know you you do the you do the
math um so yeah it's definitely sped up
but you know it takes a lot of time to
figure this stuff out and I just
think I don't know I would never be
comfortable hitting the ground running
plus you know inevitably if you want to
do four in the second year you're going
to lose control of your business
immediately because that that four
restaurant is not going to is it's a
chunk of capital yeah you've got one
that's working well I guarantee you're
going to be a minority shareholder by
the time that's done and that's not a
good thing and I I just don't think you
know again if you started a business to
actually enjoy it what's the rush yeah
one thing that I
so I love the I love the whole long-term
thinking I guess in my in my business
one thing that I I struggle with and i'
i' i' have to get your take on this is
because our business is so reliant on
the YouTube channel
and it's like you know we like 4.6 7
million subscribers now with a YouTube
channel another like 300K with a podcast
it's like things are growing but at the
same time you know subscribers there's a
lot there's a lot of churn like the
people that watched me 5 years ago and
broadly not the same people that are
watching me now every day new people are
discovering the channel and people are
stopping watching the videos because
they've gotten what they needed and
they've left now yeah like I don't
listen to much of Gary V's content
anymore even though I loved it back in
the day when I was first getting started
yeah and so there's a natural churn
there and so My worry is always like are
we now at the peak is it are we going to
you know is is this the year where we're
going to stop growing is this the year
where we're going to sort of be on the
decline and so thinking long term feels
like uh oh it feels scary because like
got to make sure we're like on 60%
margins every single year because if
we're not then it's like yeah like all
the kind of the fear associated with
that yeah do you do you did you feel
that at all in your business or like I
think you I think you definitely do I
think our our way of growing is so
different to you and that like you know
it's like cool we want to grow let's go
and open a pizzeria in Manchester or
Edinburgh or Glasgow or Bristol like
that's that's growth yeah and yours is
obviously you you have access to all
those people already so it's like a very
different yeah it's a very different
approach like like need more and better
and new yeah and try and not like
default to new because actually more and
better is like but I guess I guess the
most important thing is understand like
why people watch you right and then
doing trying to do more of that more of
that and better and more of that and
better yeah but I'm I'm reading I mean
just to you know but yes absolutely you
constantly feel I I genuinely believe
that pizza pilgrims has kind
of got you know survived because I
literally feel like every single day it
could fail tomorrow like that's my kind
of General sitting anxiety level of like
but if we didn't do that thing that we
probably don't need to do and is going
to be a lot of effort but if we don't do
it we might I might fail tomorrow might
be the over might be over I think I'm
reading at the moment Paul McCartney
biography oh interesting uh who it's
really well I just I only read Rock
biographies uh it's like my only thing
that I read unfortunately I read no
productivity book radio t-shirt yeah
there you go you see um and uh so I only
read Rock biographies but he went to um
I'm gonna forget the name the bloody
philosopher now but he basically at the
peak of Paul McCarney at the peak of The
Beatles Fame he constantly felt like it
was going to be a flash in the pan
Beatles will be forgotten and his one
thing he'd be left with was being a
songwriter so he was constantly The
Beatles kind of progression of that like
Studio stuff and like the songw writing
becoming more and more complex in nature
and was built around him going I'm going
to have to write songs for artists that
I don't necessarily chime with so I need
to constantly be like doing new stuff in
the studio to be pushing ourselves so
that when this all disappears everyone's
forgotten about the Beatles I know like
loads of different genres of songwriting
so I can go and like have a solid career
that was his driving thought that's cool
which is which is that's helpful in some
ways exactly anxiety inducing in others
yeah no exactly and I think you know
it's not the healthy but he went to see
this really really famous oh God it's
going to annoy me basically it's like
the most famous philosopher of his time
Alan what no but begin B bur Bernard uh
bertron Russell bertran Russell that's
exactly who it was he's written a good
essay In Praise of ID uh In Praise of
idleness right which I often read as
like a solid which is all about it
written like the 1920s where he's like
yeah everyone's going to stop working
because like something and people are
going to realize that they can just
chill and I'm like uhoh
okay um that's exactly what it was ber
from Russell and uh so anyway he went to
see Paul McCartney was like basically
I've got this thing it's kind of as you
may have noticed it's kind of got quite
big this prob like 1966 or something
yeah uh you know what what do you think
I should do he ber Russell was 90 at the
time like what should I do about it I'm
worried about this I'm worried about
that like and basically but R was like
you should literally enjoy it every
single day make the most of enjoying it
because it's insanely brilliant and like
don't think about anything else just
enjoy it to the m
I'm like that's that's great advice like
I'm not saying we're anywhere near that
level but like I love the idea that
someone literally on top of the world is
going I'm worried this is all going to
go wrong and what do I do with this and
the advice from beron Russell is just
have a good time that's so good that is
so good what happened during the
pandemic and how did you guys deal with
that it was spicy it was super spicy uh
should I tell you through it blowby Blow
yeah I would love it the story it was
pretty Punchy so we went so we had um
February halterm famously really big for
us it's kind of the first like thoring
of winter this says 2020 2020 February
halterm uh like you know pizza and
families is Big so it's obviously always
a big week for us had biggest week the
company ever had in February half time
and how many how many stores do you have
at that point um it's a great question I
reckon about 17 W okay something like
that so yeah 20 February 2020 and then
our rmd who is a total Legend but is
definitely on the the kind of like
germaphobe scale he's like oh you know
this thing is getting quite big like do
you think this is this is going to be a
thing and I was like this is so not
going to be a thing every time it comes
around there's some kind of bird flu it
goes away again it's nonsense obviously
we then had this like weird early
warning system where a lot of people who
work for us are Italian and we started
to get calls up from Italians being like
my moms told me that I can't come to
work like uh obviously we'd seen on the
news and it was getting big and it like
okay so this is getting closer and
closer to home but we were getting like
the real like on your doorstep human
reaction of like I'm I'm not I'm not
happy coming to work I don't know what
this is I don't so this was growing
growing uh and obviously you know we
were increasingly aware of it I went I
remember I went went around on a Sunday
I went to every Pizza of rear and just
sat and chat to the team like how do you
feel about this you know anyone who
doesn't want to work doesn't have to
work um but obviously we're not going to
be able to pay you if you choose not to
work totally respect the decision
there'll be a job there for you if you
want but you know we've got to keep
going then we had this like absolute
nuclear moment where Boris came out and
was like and this is probably early
first week of March yeah he basically
announced on the news that like people
shouldn't go to bars restaurants or
clubs y they shouldn't do it but didn't
close us down give us any kind of like
you know support y so suddenly our
Revenue which is already we would
definitely seeing flag we were
definitely star to see Revenue come down
quite aggressively by 7th 8th of March
yep then Boris comes out and was like
don't go to these places and it went
like through the roof like absolute
collapse and so we were there still open
still trading but with no one coming
yeah and it was like like literally no
one I mean like I think I think our
Revenue probably dropped by like 60 to
70% overnight uh so like I mean we were
open in trading but we knew that every
single day we were losing money yeah
like you know there's just no way that's
going to work so uh you know restaurants
famously thin margins anyway so you know
losing losing 10 20% is enough to cause
you anyway so that happened um we were
like what the hell do we do now and
basically we had to we had to make a
decision and we
decided we did two things one we sat
down and modeled out uh what we called
the apocalypse scenario oh okay which
showed six weeks of closure which was
like obviously nowhere near or ended up
having uh and we I never forget we did
it we did the spreadsheet was the four
of us senior bods in the room did the
spreadsheet pressed enter and it was
like oh actually six weeks of closure
that's all right we can survive this
this is pretty good and then do was like
oh forgot to cell a to
cellb Boom like business is gone in six
weeks like nothing left so so why is it
is it because you have to pay the rent
for the stores and you've got to pay the
staff or like yeah so we we were
modeling it like with everyone still
being paid like you know no this is
obviously before like any so any we
didn't know anything about fur come come
around then so we had this week of like
right we know that we phys the business
will implode yes so what do we do now
we've got all these stores they're
losing money that's prob scary how how
feel when you saw the it was totally
horrendous I genuinely genuinely did go
to the human element of
like what are we going to do we can't
fire all these people like what are they
going to do so we basically took the
decision that our plan was obviously you
know everyone was nervous of it and it
was like do we you know we're getting a
lot of like why are you opening like you
shouldn't be opening it's not safe blah
blah blah we were like no the best thing
we can do for the most people in this
business is to trade our asses off as
much as we can keep the pizzer Reas open
as much as we can push out and left
right Center tell the world that we're
open and trading and if you want to come
and have a pizza we're here for you and
basically give as many people as many
hours to work as we can and hope that
this all blows over basically um and we
did that and we got definitely a lot of
push back we got a lot of people telling
us that we were responsible and blah
blah blah but we were like I think this
is the best thing we can do for everyone
anyway about a week after that we got
the sort of your pizza re now need to
close everything needs to close and need
Shut by the end of today um but in that
same I think that was the day the day
they told us we had to close and it was
like you need to by 11 o'clock at night
have closed everything up and gone and
you can do delivery but nothing else um
they also announced fur and we were sat
in this meeting I getet all of us on
Zoom watching rishy reading out what
Fellers and there was speculation of
like is it going to be 40% of salary
covered is it going to be 60 yeah I
think Denmark had done 60 so we were
like seems unlikely it be more than that
and then uh came out and said we're
going to cover 80% of everyone's salary
and I you remember like we were all just
in tears we were all quite drunk
drinking like everyone was drinking
whatever their respective drink was in
their house watching this happen just
being like this is unbelievable like all
these people are going to get 80% of
their salary so the government was
covering 80% of people salary so we we
went from I think at that point we
probably had 250 people yeah we went to
250 people working for pizza pilgrims to
248 people on fur wow uh and who were
getting 8% of their salary which means
that you just pay 20% or no they
unfortunately got 80% they couldn't
afford to pay the 20 but we took the
decision at that point because we' had
so much like I'm scared to come to work
I don't want to be we were like we're
not going to do the Lio we're just going
to shut yeah and we're gonna everyone's
going to get 80% of their salary they're
going to be at home obviously I would
wish it was 100% but it's not we
subsequently topped up quite a few
people to 100% but it's difficult in an
hour's business because obviously we did
a lot of like what normal looks like but
anyway we didn't have to let anyone go
which is unbelievable uh everyone you
know everyone stayed in the company we
closed all of our pizza re and we just
we just like sat there being like okay
so this is weird we're going to survive
which was amazing because at the point
you know there was one point was like
well we'll be out of business by April
yeah um so we were sat there and then we
started getting after about two weeks of
that just going like what the [__] just
happened we started getting calls from
managers being like you know what I'm
really really bored and actually you
know if you're thinking of reopening a
Pizza Du delivery only Count Me In type
thing that started to happen and me and
James like chomping at the bit to get a
pizza back open because we were like
Jesus we had all these pizza you know
all those pizza rovens burning and now
they're all off um anyway so we decided
after we had enough of those calls from
enough people we were like let's open
one so we we reopened Victoria which had
been our most recent opening um we had
no we were in what you call a rentree
period so when you first take on a lease
you tend to agree a period of time with
a landlord where you don't pay any rent
which helps to cover some of your
capital expenditure and I think we were
in a sort of a yearlong rentree period
on that store so it's like well open
there there's no kind of awkward
conversations with landlords then about
what the rent is because we're not
paying rent anyway so it's irrelevant so
we can just open it there's no kind of
politics there it's a good location and
we'll do deliver R so that was the plan
U we started gearing up for that to
happen we're very excited to have one
open again and then um my brother being
my brother just called me one day and
was like I've had this idea to
send to to basically put the ingredients
for a pizza into a box and send it
through the post to someone and then
they could make a pizza at home while
they're stuck at home and I was like but
what do you mean he's like well what I'm
going to do I'm going to send you one so
you basically like put two dough balls
tomato sauce mozzarella parmesan flour
oil basil in literally into a pizza box
in little plastic tubs and then wrapped
it in Wool there's this proper company
called wool cool so you put it I mean
it's all pretty normal now really but
like wrapped it in Wool with a ice pack
posted it to me got it the next day
through the post uh opened it up it like
exploded everywhere just but it was cold
probed the probe the dough and it was
like safe to save you know Refrigeration
temperature it's like this this could be
a thing so we were just looking I think
for something to do on Instagram that
was a bit more interesting than
deliveroo yeah so like why don't we make
these kits and um this is before any
restaurant meal kits existed this is
like no one was doing it it was the
first one I'd ever seen and when we make
these kits we'll put them up for sale uh
we'll make 50 we'll put them up sale on
Instagram when we first on the day we
open Victoria we'll make them available
and then we'll make them in Victoria
with the team that are there and we can
just post them to people and you know
it's just a fun thing for Instagram put
50 up for sale on that Wednesday having
promoted it I think on the Monday and we
sold the first 50 in like under a minute
having plann to sell them in a week and
we were like okay this is a thing so
then we did another 50 the next day sold
them in 20 seconds and I was starting to
get my head around Shopify and I could
see that like 200 people have tried to
put him in the basket in the sort of 30
seconds of they were available and I was
like this is really interesting so on
the third day we had this like sliding
doors moment of do we do we try and
scale this sort of do obviously there's
a thing here do we try and slowly grow
it build our you know ability to make
them and like slowly expand or do we
just try and sell as M as we can well so
we were like look let's just put 1100
for sale we basically put 1100 of these
kits for sale saying like you will get
them at some point before the first of
May bearing in mind this was the 1 of
April uh we like I think you know we'll
just do that see what happens and we
sold all 1100 kits in 40 minutes wow and
it was like I think still the most
profitable hour in the history of pizza
pgri and suddenly we had this thing
where it was like holy crap this is a
thing and we were on like Sunday brunch
and we were growing this thing we you
know we had we then opened another
Pizzeria to try and meet the demand we
kept buying like chest freezers a bit
like that yeah and then we'd like get
all these ice packs and we'd fill them
like fill these chest freezers with ice
packs and be like cool so what 12 hours
later you go back you come back they're
all Frozen weren't so that just
everything was just chaos restaurants
and production facilities are like as
far apart from each other as possible
but by February 21 we were doing 10,000
units a week of this of this of this at
home that's not bad I mean it was we
were turning over more than we were in
the restaurants before Co it was mental
oh yeah that's cool so literally like
this stupid idea just grew and grew and
it meant that we had cash flow the whole
way through we had every everyone from
like the Spice Girls to stormy to all
these people made these kits it huge on
Instagram we grew our Instagram
following by like
50,000 um it was mad and uh it saved the
company remember we had cash flow the
whole way through um we were able to get
a whole lot of people off Furlow to help
us make the kits and they obiously got
their 100% payback and yeah and we just
we kind of feathered it in with and then
you we were reopening pizzer Reas and
and we still do pizz in the post today
as it was named but um it's obviously
like so much smaller than it was yeah
but we have about we have about 350 400
subscribers who get it either once a
week or subcription box type thing it
now is a subscription and revenue yeah
exactly and you know it was just it was
I mean it meant that we never ever sat
still in coid it actually like made you
know certainly for the parts of the
world where we don't have a pizeria you
know people in Edinburgh have now heard
of us where they wouldn't have done
before yeah and uh yeah it was an
amazing it was an amazing solution to
the problem problem basically love it
what are your thoughts on
franchises I've had such a weird u-turn
on this recently I was always like the
word franchise just implies like no one
gives a [__] sort of like just grow it
for the sake of growing it like
corporate
nonsense then I watched the founder have
you watched the founder no I haven't
what is that it's phenomenal a just cuz
I love Michael Keaton with all of my
heart but it's basically about the guy
who who first McDonald's and San
berardino two brothers running this
amazing restaurant Ray Croc exactly and
then he's like something about the
systems like it's a classic like
business case study of like systems like
systemize the [__] out of everything
it's got such a lovely
hypocaloric mixing machines that made
five at once not one and it was sort
like famously like no one needs to make
five at once because it's just it's
Overkill that you just make one at a
time and maybe buy two machines if you
need to make too uh anyway he gots this
call from this restaurant in San
Bernardino being like we need eight of
these machines he's like no no you can't
be right like we you know you mean you
need to eight milkshakes like no no we
need eight five spindle milkshake
machines so he drove out to see them and
that was McDonald's and he was like this
is the greatest thing ever and started
you know doing the franchise and I think
you know it's a great film you should
watch it but I guess the point is that
like where I'm at with it is like done
right and with the right selection
process your franchisee is going to be
so much more engaged potentially than
like a manager of a store now like you
know not our level but like if you if
you're you know if if you're going like
right here you go you can take over this
McDonald's person you know here's a new
McDonald's you can come and take it over
it's your business you need to pay
percentage but anything you make is
yours that person is gonna like I think
absolutely gun that business and like
look after the standards and be amazing
what they do potentially better than a
manager m and I think you know obviously
it's about picking the right things I'm
not saying that I you know I don't think
that you know we work super hard with
our managers and they're super engaged
and well I think they are they certainly
seem to be and you know done right but I
could see if you're like right we're
going to open 300 of these it would be
easier to do it with franchises than it
would be and you'd get a better outcome
for everyone um but you know it's it's
it's a difficult one because restaurant
restaurant margins are are tight and
like if you've got to give 5% to someone
that's that's a big chunk of your
potential upside um where it gets smart
with McDonald's as they basically became
the land owner and that's where they
make all their money yeah yeah um what's
the story behind Pizza
Academy so the pizza Academy opened in
uh March 2020 which is an inauspicious
time to open a restaurant uh but the
idea was that we wanted to
create I hate the idea that people think
of hospitality as like not a great job
or a good career and that it's easy
there are two things that drive me mad
um I personally believe you should go
and do your University degree then you
should go and do a year working in a
restaurant and you will learn so much
about people about teamwork about like
problem solving just general life in
that year whatever you then go on and do
will'll be you'll be better at it um so
that idea combined with the idea that
like actually to start you know if your
first shift in Pizza pilgrims is in
carnaby Street on Saturday night it's
busy and intense and not a good place to
learn so you're like wouldn't it be
great if we could have a place where was
like a central point of truth about how
we do stuff it's a pizzeria as in like
there are real live humans in there who
are customers but it's kind of quieter
and we can kind of teach people the way
to do it in a kind of controlled
environment but it is actually a real
environment and that was the idea for
the Academy so it's a space in Camden
it's it's split into three there's a
there's a small restaurant on the front
that's open all the time so like on a
Monday lunch probably about 20 seats in
the front and that's just always open
and then we have a a front of house
training section in the Middle with a
bar and like a a projector and like um
you know we kind of do c we do
everything from like mental health
awareness to uh how to do your stock
control to uh we do a big warm welcome
there once a month where all the new
joiners meet me and James and we chat
about company and stuff and then the
back we've got a back of house
recruitment so we've got like bleacher
seating you can watch and like learn
about the new menu items and it's just a
big old space where you can learn about
how to make
pizza and every head chef and manager
who starts the company now starts
through there and every one within their
first month has to go there in some
capacity to like do a course or like and
I think you know you can apply to do
more so it's interesting the people who
like really want to progress themselves
will push to be there more uh and it's
been it's been a really lovely little
lovely exercise in trying to do
something I mean it it makes it breaks
even as a pizzeria which was a hard sell
to the board because it was like we've
got to spend a whole chunk of money
building a pizza that will make no money
but it will actually help the whole
company but I generally think it has
help the whole company and I think we're
still learning really what it's about
but I want I guess my aim is that every
single person in the company can learn
something there whether it's your first
day and you're learning the absolute
Basics or meeting me or James to you
know you're a board member and you've
been in the industry for 40 years and
actually we're going to get we had a
talk of uh we had Fred syx from First
Dates come and talk to us about
Hospitality there we've had we're going
to get um uh I'm obsessed with getting
someone from an airline because I feel
like dealing with customers at 30,000 ft
that are there for 12 hours that paid
you a lot of money that are difficult
that is tough yeah and so actually what
are the SK what are the things that they
teach you British Airways or Virgin
airways whatever yeah to deal with that
because actually our person who's paid
1010 pound for a pizza and is only going
to be there 30 minutes is easy compared
to that
person nice that's cool um I read
something about you guys you employ
homeless people and ex convicts and
stuff what's the so that's what we do so
that's a big a big part of what the
academy is about as well so we've done
uh two we've worked with two Charities
one called The Passage based in Victoria
and another called only a pavement away
and it's about uh exactly that giving uh
ex-convicts or people who've kind of who
are homeless or have been homeless kind
of a second start in life I guess and I
just feel so fundamentally that
hospitality is a great match of that
because it it's almost all about
attitude and not about skill obviously
it's skill to be a pizza chef and like
know you learn your skills but we can
teach you the skills it's very much
about your attitude and I think giving
people a chance to kind of come and you
know readis discover themselves
surrounded by people they're not like on
their own they're not you know they're
they're in a support network is a great
way to do it so we're trying to do we're
trying to do um more of that as we as as
much as we can to to bring people back
off the streets into into work yeah this
is one thing that I've been thinking
about a lot
around what's the point of growing the
business because like once you hit a
certain profit margin you're just like
ah like more money in the ebit sort of
uh PDF is not that personally meaningful
and so I'm trying to figure out for our
business what is the what's the service
component like giving back and stuff and
it feel feels kind of cringe talking
about as well because vir signaling and
all that [__] yeah but I'm curious like
how do how do you think about
that I mean I absolutely have obsessed
about this I think it's you know you
know if you really push me I'll get on
to like sort of failing of capitalism
type type thing of like we just always
want more and like if more people knew
where stop
was everyone would be better off
probably but I I I think in a very small
way that doesn't really work for
something like even piz pilgrims
because you're right like there's no
need for the company to grow but if it
doesn't grow the whole mindset around it
changes now I think the question is can
it grow
does it have to grow in scale could it
grow in like stature or responsibility
like that but if it's not growing in one
of those ways everyone's going to lose
interest or selling our will lose
interest yeah that's the thing and and
it's not giving genuinely and I mean
this in the kind of the most obvious way
like our great people need to be growing
and if you're you know if you're a head
chef today what's next yeah and if it's
not well we've grown so I now need to
look after two other head chefs and move
into a higher level or do you know what
we now need a head of health and safety
so I'm going to go and be that or we
need someone in the creative food team
I'm going to go and be that if you're
not growing if we'd stopped at 10 we
wouldn't have the money to have a food
team or a health and safety person I
have a third part third party health and
safety team but um
so yeah I think you know at a small
level you've got to grow to kind of give
your team opportunity yeah but the
danger is you do just end up you know if
you're doing that the wrong way if
you're taking then debt on to grow and
then you've got service to debt and then
it sort of it's a vicious circle so
we've always been very very conscious
that if we're growing we're growing
because we kind of feel like we're going
to we're going to break it the seams if
we don't yeah interesting um I did a
good interview with Steve Steve Brett
yesterday and he was saying that um one
of the main reasons for their grow or
like one of the ways he thinks about it
is if a team member is not challenged in
their job they will leave within 6
months 100% and so he's constantly like
keeping an eye on like making sure
everyone is one foot out the one foot in
outside of the comfort zone to make sure
there's like some level of discomfort so
that they then feel like they're part of
something and you know just in general
like the feeling of growth for people is
just an addictive feeling and I found
that with my first business I was
teaching courses helping people get into
medical school we like grew we grew we
grew and then 2015 2016 we dipped in
revenue and all of a sudden it was just
like night and day difference between
how I felt about it I was just like oh
God now either we double down on this
and really make it grow but now my
heart's not in it do I really like it
and growth
weirdly the stuff that I was doing to
grow that business I wouldn't have said
I was prly fun it was like a lot of
admin a lot of logistics lot of bloody
printing booklets and making sure they
arrive at the Manchester hotel room and
making sure the team members who taking
the train there's no strikes to get
there on time so we can teach the kids
that are there and yeah but it was
growing and there was something so
exciting about the fact that it was
growing and as soon as it stopped
growing now all of those things are just
like an absolute nightmare to deal with
and I'm like why the hell am I spending
my time doing this stuff have you found
that at all like growth is
addictive is addictive and I think it's
you know it's so hard it's so hard to
start again and I think with coid you
really did have to start again and I
think you you really were like back down
again like rebuilding and like some of
the stuff you thought You' done you were
kind of having to pretty fundamentally
rebuild so yeah I totally I totally
totally get that and I think you know
the thing I say most is like I just want
to be learning like everything else is
irrelevant if I'm not learning something
I'm going to be bored and I think that
applies to you know the vast majority of
people in our business and we really
want to employ people who are driven by
that because I think a lot of
people you know I think there are two
types of people who will come into you
know come into our business and and be a
KP which is like you know washing the
pots and like you're starting wrong on
the ladder and one of them is like this
is the starting run on the ladder and
I'm looking at the prep Chef going how
do I be a prep chef and then I'm looking
at the junior Chef being like how do I
do that that that is the person I think
you know we want to have in Pizza
Pilgrims really but then there were
plenty of people who just you know some
some of them worked for us for many many
years who don't want that they they want
you know work is not what drives them
they come to work they do their job they
go home and what drives them is family
or you know Community or you know
whatever it is it doesn't matter but
like so you've got to be able to do both
you've got to you've got to accept that
some people are just not built that way
they don't want that constant next thing
they just want you know to know what to
know what their job looks like to get a
fair pay for it take it home and spend
that how they want and I think it's
it's a hard line to walk but I mean I
always said we'd never go past 15 and
here we are 24 yeah so you know either
I'm a liar or I'm an idiot or I don't
know but yeah it's just making sure
that's it's you know we've been lucky
and that we've never got where where it
gets bad is when you're doing it for the
wrong reasons when you're you know when
you're like oh this one didn't work so
I'm going to do two and I'll get
economies to scale and then it will work
like no it won't or I've taken out a
massive loan and it's not working so I'm
gonna have to like keep going to you
know that's that that's the bit that if
that's driving you then you should
probably stop yeah there was a a good
quote I heard at a business conference
which is that like if you think you're a
bad parent with one kid then for God's
sake don't have a second one thinking
you're going to be a better parent for
two yeah yeah exactly exactly although
there is a weird thing about like you
know obviously not in the very early
days but like the kids will look after
each other so like economies SC maybe
maybe the businesses are doing that
maybe having more of them just means
there's more of a network but it's
interesting for us sorry draw that out
but it's interesting for us building
that Network in London is a real thing
and like you know the pizzer reers can
help each other out and like you know
I've run out of that cool I can get that
sorted for you no problem but then you
have a new thing where like we opened in
Nottingham we have one Pizzeria in
Nottingham and it's not near to any of
our other Pizzeria and they are very
much more an island like you know that
person has to be so much more on it
there's no room for like do you know
what I run out of X because no one can
save you yeah and it's a very different
it's a very different mentality like
when you when you realize having one is
there's nowhere to hide how do you
balance family life like married two
kids and also found a business in the
food food industry that's growing for
the last 10 years yeah it's uh I mean
it's definitely not easy and I
definitely don't don't balance it as
well as I potentially could I mean I'm I
guess my problem really is I'm I'm kind
of there a lot other than like
physically at home I try and get home
and sort of you know certainly be home
for bedtime and all that kind of stuff
and don't you know I don't leave the
house at six you know I see the kids in
the morning and the evening and I take
them to school quite a lot and that kind
of thing but am I like mentally there no
quite a lot of the time because my
phone's going off and you know I've got
a thing and I'm I'm there with the kids
but I'm actually replying to an email or
dealing with some kind of emergency and
I think that that's the been the problem
for me and certainly what my wife would
say is like you know well she basically
like if if iPhones existed when we met
we wouldn't be together like which I
mean I know they did exist but I didn't
have one and I think yeah you know they
are they are a little like a little
attention sucking nightmare aren't they
and business both I was talking actually
specifically about iPhones just there's
no Escape yeah like there's no escape
from it and it's you know you've got to
got to learn to turn it off and I'm
trying my best but
nice have have there been any sort of
rules or systems you've added to your
life that have been helpful in
maintaining this sort of Harmony or
balance I mean I I I'll be honest I've
tried like almost all of those like
things you know all those kind of
productivity
tools I have never
found I've always found it a bit like
doing a sort of revision timetable which
I'm just like I feel like I'm just
putting off doing the stuff rather than
like actually I'm spending all the time
you know color coding it and making it
all perfect and so actually you know
I've it's interesting at the moment I'm
just at this weird transition which I'm
trying to sort of resist of like um we
now have a sort of uh uh a lady who
looks after to
the uh management team Diaries
essentially and I've always been I just
don't really understand why it would
help me to bring in someone to help me
with this because I feel like I know
exactly what's going on in my week yep I
know where my priorities are and what's
and I feel like I'm gonna have to like
communicate all of this to someone else
yeah for them to do it and I I don't
really feel like it's going to make my
life easier so I've sort of resisted
that idea of the
future um yeah I I I just used I I'm
obsessed about my calendar have a family
calendar and a work calendar and they
you know making sure that they talk to
each other and like you know everyone's
aware of what's what's going on my wife
works she works for um she actually also
works for a restaurant business she
works for Dume oh yeah um so she you
know she's busy as well so yeah sadly no
no exciting kind of life hacks in there
just just just got yeah I I think
staying close to it and you know not
letting someone else manage your diary
to me that makes no sense but
um final question it comes from uh anav
from our telegram Community what lessons
have you learned from running Pizza
pilgrims that you could share with
aspiring
entrepreneurs I I think you know it's
such a cliche thing but like no one know
no one knows what they're doing like
especially in restaurants so don't
overthink it
like if you've got an idea and you like
it think of any way you can test it that
you know will give you a bit more
insight into where the idea is is a goer
whether you actually enjoy it whether
it's something that's you know there's a
need for it without quitting your job so
you don't have to like throw everything
in on day one just start testing the
fences a little bit but the other thing
is don't go away to my mind like you
know I could have gone right I want to
run a pizza company what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go and work for Pizza
Express for 10 years and figure out
exactly how they do everything and then
I can go away and and I don't think that
would have set me up any more to for
Success than just having a crack and
doing it your way uh and I think if you
are that way minded if if the white BL
piece of paper is something that excites
you you'll figure it out because that
that's how you're buil if you're a
person who likes the structure and likes
to know that their pay packet lands on
the last Friday of every month and likes
to know that there is a team of people
out there to help you I think you've got
to think really really hard about
whether you want to run your own
business um because I think I think
there's definitely a danger I I love
that it's celebrated more and that like
you know entrepreneurship which is not a
word that I particularly love uh is kind
of now genuinely considered something to
Aspire to rather than something that
only crazy people do I feel like that
has changed you know they now you know
entrepreneurs are now like very much put
up on a pedestal was I think 20 years
ago that was not the case it was your
Gordon geckos that was on a pedestal
yeah 30 years ago probably um and so you
know I think it's good it's on a
pedestal but I think the danger is that
it's like it's for everyone or you know
that it's like the ultimate goal and I I
just I don't think it is I think it's
fantastic for certain kinds of people
but it is it has downsides and it you
know it's not you
know we can't all be the guitarist in Le
Zeppelin right like everyone wants to be
but and it looks cool but it had I'm
sure it had some massive downsides and
not everyone can do it and so like I I
really think you know it's a great thing
to try and like you know try it in the
most you if if you want to start a food
business go and do a like a weekend
market for one Saturday and see if you
enjoy it because you know you might hate
it um so yeah I think I think
it's I guess my actual lesson in the
deep in there was like don't overthink
it don't think that everyone knows
everything you don't do don't know and
like give it just give it a shot like
what's the Worst That Could
Happen nice it's a great place to end
this Tom thank you so much thanks man
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye